hey everyone we have an exciting topic
for today this video will walk you
through the top 10
highest paying jobs for the year 2021 as
we are nearing the end of 2020 now we
have analyzed and understood the high
demand jobs in the coming year
the list in this video can help you plan
for your career in 2021.
let's start by looking at the job role
we have in the 10th position
an information security analyst role he
or she
is entrusted with protecting computer
networks and organizations
they install security measures to
protect computer systems
they investigate security breaches
document them
fix vulnerabilities and perform
penetration testing
coming to the skills you should be good
at networking and must have a good
understanding of firewalls
proxies and idps concepts holding cyber
security certifications will help you a
lot
wepro hpe microsoft and robert half are
a few companies that hire
information security analysts in the
united states an
information security analyst earns about
360 000
and in india about 30 lakh rupees per
annum
now at number 9 we have the role of an
rpa developer
rpa developers are professionals who
create develop and implement
rpa systems they set up automated
processes to increase efficiency they
look into deployment of rpa components
like bots
robots and development tools rpa
developers possess
a rich skill set and ideally have a
software development background
they need to know c plus dot net as well
as scripting languages
you should have a sound knowledge of
leading automation tools examples
uipath and blueprism we have uipath
colavera siemens and cigna hiring rpa
developers
rpa developers earn nearly 118 000
in the us and in india they earn more
than 11 lakh rupees per annum
moving on to number eight we have mobile
application developer
a mobile application developer
researches and develops protocols and
applications for ios
and android platforms they design
interfaces in order to improve user
experience
they also collaborate with the product
development team to propose new features
a mobile application developer should
have knowledge of ui
and frameworks in javascript such as
react native and angular
they should be familiar with the concept
of cyber security
in order to develop safe and flawless
applications
and be proficient in java c css
and html5 oracle philips wells fargo and
ntt data services hire mobile
application developers
holding a few years of experience mobile
application developers can earn up to
230
000 in the us and in india they can earn
up to 30 lakh rupees per annum
at number seven we have the role of
blockchain developer a blockchain
developer researches
designs develops and tests blockchain
technologies
they build infrastructure and set up
security measures to protect against
cyber attacks and help to optimize
blockchain protocols
blockchain developers build
decentralized apps and supervise the
entire network a blockchain developer
should be proficient in computer
networking cryptography and data
structures
they should have a fundamental knowledge
of programming languages like java and
python
they must have experience with
blockchain protocols such as bitcoin and
ethereum
infosys dell cognizant and ibm hire
blockchain developers
in the united states a blockchain
developer with just a few years of
experience earns nearly 170
000 and in india about 22 lakh rupees
per annum now
at number six we have devops engineer
devops engineer work with developers and
the it team to oversee code releases
they code and script to ensure
continuous development integration and
deployment of software
they also automate tests deploy the code
and monitor it
devops engineer need to have good
programming skills knowledge of
javascript
python ruby or perl is required he or
she should have various devops tools and
technologies
they must be able to collaborate
effortlessly with different team members
we have ibm zoom deloitte and tech
mahindra hiring devops engineers
experienced devops engineers can earn up
to 800
000 dollars in the united states and in
india around 40 lakh rupees per annum at
number five we have a role of a big
data engineer big data has been a
revolution in every business sector over
the last 10 years
big data engineers store process and
analyze data
they develop design test and maintain
the big data architecture in an
organization
they should have in-depth knowledge of
hadoop spark rdbms and nosql
they should have hands-on experience
with languages such as java and python
and they need to know tools like hive
and pig they must also possess
data warehousing skills companies like
ernst and young
robert half mastercard and amazon hire
big data engineers
big data engineers earn 300 000 in the
united states
and in india nearly 30 lakh rupees per
annum next at number four we have full
stack developer a full stack developer
works with both the front and back ends
of a website
they tackle projects that involve
building user facing websites and work
with clients during the planning phase
of a project
to become a full stack developer you
must know html and css
you should also be proficient in
javascript and its frameworks
you need to be familiar with server side
languages like ruby
php python and net finally you must know
how to work with mysql
oracle and mongodb fedex dell equifax
and accenture actively hire full stack
developers
full stack developers in the us earn
nearly 226 000
and in india about 35 lakh rupees per
annum at number 3 we have cloud
architect
a cloud architect is an information
technology expert
who supervises an organization's cloud
computing system
and works on cloud application designs
cloud architects work with devops
engineers and developers
to ensure that the right technology is
being built they should know cloud
computing technologies like aws
azure and gcp they should be proficient
in programming languages like java
python and c-sharp they must know tools
such as kubernetes and docker
companies like huawei amazon web
services unisys and medtronic hire cloud
architects in the us an experienced
cloud architect can earn nearly 240
000 and in india anywhere between 16 to
50 lakh rupees per annum moving on at
number two we have
product manager product managers are
responsible for the product development
for an organization
they guide the success of a product and
supervise its improvement
they are the brains behind the business
strategies of a product
product managers must be strategic
thinkers they should understand data
business competencies and market trends
they must be technically sound with
respect to their industry wells fargo
oracle hitachi and apple hire product
managers
in the us product managers earn up to
250 000
and in india as high as one crore rupees
per annum
finally let's look at which job role we
have at number one
and that is the role of a data scientist
a data scientist is a professional who
makes use of different statistical
methods
data analysis techniques and machine
learning to comprehend and analyze data
to arrive at crucial business
conclusions
a data scientist should be proficient in
microsoft excel
sql and no programming languages like
python r
and java they should be good at machine
learning and deep learning concepts
familiarity with apache hive pig and
spark is also necessary
companies hiring for data scientists
include shell facebook
halliburton and google a data scientist
with a fair amount of experience
earns up to eight hundred thousand
dollars in the us
and in india nearly 60 lakh rupees per
annum
and there you go those are the top 10
highest paying jobs in 2021
with that we've reached the end of this
video do you agree with our top 10 list
will data scientists still be in the
sexiest job of 21st century
let us know in the comments thank you
for watching this video and stay tuned
for more from simply learn